et de quoi on se parle aujourd'hui
parlent de cette petite bête là et cette
petite bête là c'est quoi et bien c'est
la nouvelle trottinette électrique de
chez home is ennemis électriques
scooters 3 et le mini électriques
scooters 3 il est cool parce qu'on peut
faire des dérapages avec mon pas que
regarder
c'est vrai que ça prenne forme parce
qu'ils ont mis des nouveaux freins à
disques de ce que j'ai tout vous
expliquer ça freine hyper forte
[Musique]
chez xiaomi j'avais testé le mil
électriques scooters c'était la toute
première trottinette qui avait très bien
marché david carton d'ailleurs c'était
un carton plein à l'époque j'avais testé
le mini électriques scooters pro le
modèle prend parce que la première
trottinette à la dame petit souci c'est
que sur le plat salé très bien mais en
monte ça monte pas le pro ça monte très
bien la première version s'il n'y avait
pas de france après n'est pas du tout
ici avec semi électriques scooters 3 il
rejoint ce qui est bien c'est que elle
vient avoir de la puissance on va
jusqu'à 600 watts pour monter en quote
c'est pas mal puis surtout si vous avez
des freins et des freins qui freine et
ça c'est bien parce que lorsque vous
preniez des pentes décote avec le mary
queen scooter des fois il fallait sauter
tout lâcher ici vous freinez alors
attention le point un petit peu
différent c'est que ça ferait et ça
freine tellement fort que si vous fait
pas gaffe rey a vite fait de passer du
temps une petite halte au bon il faut
apprendre à maîtriser sa machine mais
sinon ça fred et du confort des
dérapages avec
[Musique]
25 km ça c'est la loi française qui n'a
pas donc votre trottinette elle peut pas
faire plus de 25 km mais avant on allait
jusqu'à 25 km et si on a gagné un petit
peu on va jusqu'à 30 km nouveauté qui
est intéressant c'est ce qu'à la fra ray
disc à l'arrière avec double tambours ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que quand
j'additionne bien petite manette de la
wii ça bouge déjà ça quand ça bouge
c'est joli mais surtout ça veut dire que
ça ferait que ça prenne force à vos
besoins votre ou alors l'idée ici c'est
d'apprendre à freiner pour faire super
gaffe parce que si vous bourriner vous
avez vous coincez vous risquez de vous
faire mal vous avez toujours des petits
réfléchissent heures et si d'un côté
l'autre pour venir nous voir alors truc
un peu relou accès trottinette je vous
le dis c'est que ces détenus à chambray
trottinette vous avez deux types de
pneus vous avez soit inclus à chambres à
air comme ce que vous allez sur shiomi
et c'est ce qui a nommé en terme de
tenue de route et sécurité c'est le top
sauf que quand il faut changer la
chambre et le pneu c'est un peu la merde
il faut venir retirer ces petites
plaques la faute ou dévisser faut
enlever alors ça se fait ça prend une
petite demi-heure il ya des petites
utopies pour vous expliquer sur internet
mais c'est pascal plus simple il existe
des pneus pleins comme sur ce que je
trouve sur notre marque et les pneus
pleins c'est pas bien en termes de
sécurité moi je suis tombé avec une
trottinette segway avec coque de plein
vous assure que c'est pas ouf donc là en
terme de sécurité on a un truc qui est
bien ça freine un peu fort mais il faut
apprendre à réguler sa en termes de
confort en termes de sécurité on a un
produit qui est vraiment cool on est
encore en alu mais oui ils sont pas là
pour rigoler si on me accord on a lu
qualité aérospatiale qu'on nous envoyait
sur la lune bientôt né voit alors le
truc qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
peut appuyer très facilement cette
frontière tous se situe juste là ici
vous avez tous qu'open vous prenez hop
vous tirez vous descendez la bague on
fait gaffe à pas se cogner quand on est
là alors bien en bas un petit point dur
mais on le met bien en bas au clip la
halle et une fois qu'on a cru et on peut
la prendre pour l'élève et là on peut la
prendre pour faire du sport on monte on
descend sinon on peut l'emmener
facilement on la met dans le coffre
d'une voiture tantôt et ses treize kilos
alors 13 kg en termes d'alter ça fait un
peu lourd mais un peu quand même
s'amuser mais surtout apprendre à bout
de bras ça se fait moi je montre cinq
étages avec j arrive après lorsque vous
voulez la prendre et repartir c'est
pareil
elle vient lever ici renault on vient
bien le clip c'est là
ça tient bien et ensuite on n'oublie pas
de virer cette équipe est là on est
parti parce que si vous laissez la
béquille vous allez tomber rien c'est ça
qui est assez marrant haut niveau la
préservation de votre batterie vous
expliquiez en fait votre niveau de matri
inférieur à 30% et que vous l'avez pas
recharger pendant dix jours et bien le
système intelligent de préservation de
la batterie qu'est ce qui va faire bien
il va mettre votre batterie en veille
pour venir la protéger et éviter
qu'elles risquent d'endommager donc ça
c'est par ex les petits points de
détails que les petites techno mais
c'est relativement intéressante si on
veut emmener sa trottinette un peu plus
loin dans le temps on a une protection
contre les courts-circuits une
protection contre les surintensités
double protection contre les surcharges
et on a une protection contre les
décharges excessive une résistance à la
température et une protection contre les
sous tension va et on a une batterie de
7650 milan terreur avec une recharge 71
au niveau de votre affiche quand vous
avez plusieurs choses déjà votre petit
bouton là qui vous servir un petit peu à
tout faire plusieurs vitesses ça c'est
le mode piéton vous êtes de 0 à 5
km/heure double clic vous passez en mode
standard de 0 à 20 km/heure et vous re
double cliquer et vous passez en mode
sport de 0 à 25 km heure alors savait
que celui-là il est un peu plus pêchue
mais au niveau de l'autonomie dirait un
petit peu moins alors vous le voyez si
votre niveau vous voyez on se rapproche
doucement de la fin mais il faut dire
que autant depuis un petit moment déjà
et si vous appuyez une fois vous venez
activer le petit éclairage qui est
devant l'intensité lumineuse ici baisse
s'est passé c'est une question de
répartition de de la batterie on voit un
peu moins bien indécise je l'enlève on
voit un peu mieux on voit un peu moins
bien on voit un peu mieux et pour
revenir l'éteindre cette année puis l'on
ait la même chose pour tenir la démarrer
[Musique]
alors bientôt qu'ici qui a laissé marc
andreu recule pas n'est pas peur c'est
qu'on est de la récupération d'énergie
cinétique ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que lorsque je suis pas en train
d'accélérer que je laisse la trottinette
avancer comme ça eh bien je vais
récupérer un petit peu d'énergie pour
gagner en autonomie exactement la même
chose lorsque j'ai rien freiné ici je
récupère de l'énergie bon alors ça reste
minime mais bon tout ce qui est bon à
prendre il faut le prendre pour gagner
un petit peu quelques kilomètres et un
peu d'autonomie elle regarde ça tu vois
ça c'est du 8,5 pouces à l'avant et
également à l'arrière alors y'a un truc
qui me rend la charge maximale ici c'est
100 kg donc toi et moi dessus déjà ça
passe pas après il ya un truc est très
rigolo sérieux le disque à trottinette
le mode piéton et n'a vraiment pas du
temps le la trottinette elle est valable
pour les gens de 18 à 50 ans ça veut
dire que si tu as 51 ans tu peux qu'en
faire c'est à 52 ans d'oubli 55 ans est
dangereux alors je sais pas pourquoi est
ce qu'ils disent que les gens vont faire
de l'ostéoporose et risquent de se péter
le le coccyx j'en sais rien donc voilà
donc de 18 à 50 ans donc si vous avez 49
ans c'est peut-être pas un truc trop
rentable pour vous coiffer l'isère quand
même pas beaucoup de personnes sportives
à plus de 50 ans et qui ont plus la
forme que des gens qui ont une vingtaine
d'années tu comprends pas donc si comme
il faut changer cette limitation d'âge
c'est un peu ridicule de l'eau bah non
non non alors ip54 alors on va éviter
pour autant 2 2 laisse balader contre
tombe beaucoup beaucoup d'eau déjà parce
que vous êtes mouillés c'est pas bien
d'être trop mouillé prix on peut aimer
vous le regardez mes courriers mais par
contre elle sera éteinte alors l'idée ce
n'est pas d'aller se baigner dans une
piscine avec une trottinette ça ne
roulent pas à fond d'une piscine mais
pour autant si elle rencontre un peu
d'eau ça va à l'équipe et 54 pour se
recharger vous avez un petit câble vous
venez de mettre juste là or après
regardez vous leur posez hop là c'est
protéger ses biens et surtout ici elle
se recharge en
5,5 heures ça veut dire qu'il faut
anticiper si vous commencez a manqué un
petit peu oui la jeune demi heure devant
moi je vais la branchez vous allez pas
repartir à fond 5.5 à anticiper les
chargements tech la nuit quand vous
voulez mais anticipée
réconfort dans tout ça ça raconte quoi
cent des petites rues pavées comme ce
que vous avez ici c'est pas optimisé si
vous avez trop de pavés vous avez
l'impression que le cerveau une bouche
dans votre tête ce que vous avez
absolument aucun amortisseurs dessus
c'est un point raide mais c'est vraiment
une petite crotte pour faire de l'urbain
on va parleurs un truc trop trop dingo
tout ce qui va être beau drôle et ça va
bien mais je vous dis une fois de plus
ses bouquets l'amortir parce qu'elle ne
fera pas donc pas hésité à venir sauter
sur place lorsqu'un petit dos d'âne en
termes de confiance et son air mais ça
fait pas je verdict final ça ça va pas
mal c'est très pratique c'est une bonne
trop tard après le tarif il est pas
cadeau non plus 404 euros mais qu'on a
un petit outil de déplacement urbain qui
fonctionne plutôt bien on peut venir
sauter dessus on a différents modes
c'est assez secure ça c'est bien au
niveau du foie pour moi c'est le gros
point positif et par rapport à la
version une ici on va venir monter un
peu plus la cote ont pas s'envoler on
veut dire monter un peu plus les coach
aime bien se trouve bien vu cette
trottinette c'est vrai que ça se calme
un petit budget quand même on est
quasiment à 500 balles mais pour autant
le travail qui est fait là est plutôt
bien fait le produit est beau bien fini
j'aime bien les matériaux choisis après
reste à voir si vous avez 49 ans parce
qu'à 49 envoyer ses pompes pas donc si
vous avez moins de 50 ans entre 18 et 50
ans c'est bizarre ça je m'approche ont
fait ça mais non mais j'aime bien c'est
plutôt que tout un joli produits de
mobilité urbaine point négatif c'est
venir changer les pneus ça ça a toujours
été le cas je suis mis c'est pas nouveau
c'est hyper hyper guerrière a vous de me
dire en bas en commentaire vous a déjà
une 32 shiomi ou une autre marque un
point il me le dira jeudi si elle vous
intéresse le lien est en bas d'un
description mois je m'en vais les gens
virage sur les pavés donc là je le
cerveau qui va secouer un petit peu
femme réveillée allez bisous
moi j'veux qu'on passait vite là
[Musique]
m